April 28th, 29th and
30th, save the date.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
Zack Snyder released a new Justice League
dark Side trailer video teasing
something really big.
A lot of people had questions about it.
So this will be my break down
video explaining
what's going on, what he's teasing
in a lot of the connections
with the upcoming movies
in what's happening with the big James
Gunn reboot.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos, all the videos
for everything that winds up happening.
We have Shazam
Fury of the Gods coming out.
I have a Post-Credits scene video
that'll post really soon for that to leave
people wondering what's going on
because there's so much chaos.
And then Zack Snyder comes out and drops
this big dark side trailer like, Surprise
Laura Dark Side says, Be prepared,
Something is coming.
You probably recognize the dark side.
VOICEOVER In the trailer
is the voice of reporter who voices
Dark Side in the Justice League.
Snyder cut doing a new promo for Zack
Snyder's teaser for this big event.
This happening in April
and Elias is terrified we will stop.
Not just when he dropped the trailer
on his Twitter,
he used the hashtag full circle.
It's meant to be a reference to him
starting the DCU,
like this whole big thing
with the Man of Steel movie,
because as you probably guessed, April 22,
the 30th is three days.
What this is probably a teaser
for is a new Snyder con where he'll screen
each of his three DC movies
each of the days like Man of Steel.
Then I'll do the Batman v Superman
Ultimate Cut,
and then he'll do the Justice League.
Snyder cut on the last day
doing new commentary for the movies
during the watch along.
He's done this before in the past.
The same old thing where he shows off
concept art.
He talks about deleted
scenes, extra things
that weren't released on DVD and Blu rays.
Let's let's turn the camera.
Ding, ding, ding, ding.
The lot of Barbie movies I see.
Yeah, it's my secret passion.
Kids also use this. Oh, there it is.
So when he does these, you do learn
a lot of cool new things about the movies.
Behind the scenes stuff.
He releases a lot of deleted scenes
to publicly Warner Brothers and James
Gunn have said about the big reboot
that he's doing with the DCU
is they're calling it the DCU.
Now, to begin with,
this is like the giant list of projects
and how everything fits in.
Some of
it will be considered genuine elseworlds
like the Matt Reeves Batman
movies of Robert Pattinson.
And then there'll be the connected
DCU Universe where all the recasting stuff
is happening.
According to James Gunn,
that will start with the Flash.
Movies like Shazam
Fury of the Gods is coming out.
As of me posting this video, technically
that's meant to be inside the DCU,
but they have loose connections to the DCU
in a way that's ambiguous enough
that they could say
the characters could come back,
even though I expect there to be a lot of
recasting with the Shazam characters.
When we get to the Flash movie,
that's still DCU,
but the events of that movie
will set up a reboot into the DCU,
like The Flash will be messing
with Things. Flashpoint
Style is based on the flashpoint storyline
with a bunch of changes.
The way he talks about the Blue
Beetle movie
that's coming out later this year
is that it's kind of set off by itself.
It's ambiguous enough that they can say
it is connected to the new DCU
and it won't cause
any big continuity problems.
But the actual beginning
of all these recasting the DCU itself,
James Gunn views as being the Superman
legacy movie, which he has now announced
that he's directing,
like he's writing and directing it.
It'll be a new version of Superman
that's younger.
It's like a Superman Year two movie,
kind of like the way Matt Reeves
did Batman, Year two in the Batman movie.
Henry Cavill did say that
there was potential
he could come back eventually as Superman.
But I think we're talking
crisis on infinite Earths multiverse stuff
way down the road.
Speaking of deleted scenes,
we do know once upon a time, Zack Snyder
planned on doing a trilogy of Justice
League movies.
But what happened is way back in December
2015, Jim Lee said that
Zack Snyder brought him onto the project
to draw these giant,
like ten foot tall storyboards
with the pitch for Justice League two.
In Justice League
three to convince the studio
to spend the money
to make all three movies.
But what I'll do is I'll just read
what the story is
and talk about where this all fits in.
So he starts by saying,
Although originally pitched as one film,
we believe the character
arcs of our heroes and villains,
along with the epic Battle with Dark Side,
which unites the league, the world
and the entire DC universe warrants two
films instead of just doing one sequel.
He goes on to say, However,
this does not mean that you have two films
centered on dark sides
Invasion, rather justice League
two would be a very grounded,
personal and character driven film
that would follow the Justice League
both together and separately,
as they mend old wounds on the road
to becoming better and stronger heroes.
While Lex Luthor recruits
a league of his own, the Injustice League
made up of revenge driven villains
introduced in the Heroes solo films Doctor
Maru from Wonder Woman two
That was actually Doctor Poison,
I think originally in Zack Snyder's idea.
They would have introduced
Doctor Poison in a bigger way
during the sequel to Wonder Woman.
Captain Cold from the Flash movie ORM
and Black Manta from the Aquaman movie,
and the Riddler from Ben Affleck's
version of the Batman movie.
These villains would link
all of the DC films together.
Now, remember, this is back in 2015,
so it's the original version of the spin
off films.
Those wound up changing a little bit, like
the Aquaman movie changed a little bit.
The Flash Flashpoint
movie has changed a little bit.
The Wonder Woman movies
have changed a little bit.
Then he goes on to say,
like Empire Strikes Back in the last Harry
Potter film, Justice League
two would end with a cliffhanger,
revealing only at the end of the film.
Lex and his league
are connected to Dark Side.
Then flash forward
five years into the future where Dark Side
has taken Earth.
That's basically the nightmare future that
we see at the end of the Justice League.
Snyder Cut.
Then he goes on to describe
the hero's arcs through parts two and two.
A With Lois's
help, the Back from the Dead,
Superman will learn to become
Clark Kent again.
Feeling more human than ever,
he and Lois start a family.
Remember how they teased
Lois was pregnant?
Wonder Woman would reconnect
with the Amazons and her mother,
eventually becoming their new queen
and rejoining these isolationist warriors
with the outside world,
meaning connecting them.
Obscura with the outside world.
Aquaman, with the help of Meera,
will bring the Seven Kingdoms together.
Seven Kingdoms of Atlantis
originally becoming the one true
king building a new alliance
between the oceans and the surface.
That was with the whole Unite.
The Seven tagline was about
Unite the Seven Kingdoms of Atlantis
before Atlantis sank into the ocean,
The Flash will free himself from the past,
releasing his father from prison
with Cyborg's help and learning how
to master his time traveling abilities.
Literally becoming able
to be in two places at once.
Cyborg
will evolve both into the modern day
God of the digital age
and into a human once again
in Batman will ultimately sacrifice
his life for the unlikely friends
and the woman he loves leaving
behind a legacy that will never truly die.
But he starts with the plot of Justice
League
two by saying the Justice League United.
We open with the Justice League in action
during a natural disaster, working
as the efficient, powerful team
they become weeks after the first Justice
League movie ends.
They act together.
They save lives.
In the aftermath,
the Justice League return
at the only headquarters
they know, the Bat Cave Bruce secretly
meets with Lois, both of them
still searching for Lex Luther.
The meeting ends after Lois tells Bruce
that Superman needs her more than ever.
Bruce knows Lois is hiding something else.
Probably the pregnancy.
He was going to send this whole Batman
Lois Lane romance through the sequels
that would play out that he talks
about Lex Luthor recruiting the Injustice
League.
Meanwhile, deep in the Brazilian jungle,
Lex locates Dr.
Maru. That's Dr.
Poison from the Wonder Woman movie
outside of Central City in Iron Heights
Penitentiary.
Lex finds Leonard Snart, Captain Cold,
where he was left
at the end of the Flash movie,
or where he would have been left
at the end of the Flash movie.
It offers him a chance to advance his
weaponry and take down the fastest
man alive, upgrade
his cold gun with alien technology.
Then there's this whole sequence
within Intercutting between the Injustice
League and the Justice League characters
in Metropolis.
Superman asks Lois Lane
what she was going to tell him
as he hears
the second heartbeat inside of her.
Then is the lasso of truth is giving Diana
all these visions.
She suddenly sees a vision of herself
as a dark Diana, as the goddess of war,
battling with Superman.
She kills him.
This is probably another vision
of a potential Knightmare future.
Then, as Batman returns
from the wilderness back to the back cave
in Alfred, they revealed that Lex Luther
has found all three mother boxes.
Then it's a three Rivers Dam.
Helicopters surveyed
the area as Lex is on the scene
and activates all three mother boxes.
His true plan
to destroy the Justice League
and take the power
of the anti-life equation for his own.
Then his three
mother boxes are coming together in Lex
Luthor thinks that he's achieved his goal.
A boom tube opens
dark side and Assad step out.
As you would expect, Darkside
promptly takes the power
of the anti-life equation for himself.
Then, back at the site of the battle, Lex
Luthor reveals Darkside has the power
to kill Superman, and Darkside
acknowledges him and says,
I don't want to kill him.
I want him to submit.
So that sort of explains
why you have this evil
Superman in the nightmare timelines.
Then back in the Batcave, Batman finds out
what's happened with Dark Side killing
Lois Lane.
Superman turns on him immediately, becomes
Evil Superman and tries to kill Batman.
Then Justice Lex Luthor is basking
in his victory over the Justice League.
Evil Superman shows up
and burns him on the spot.
In this sort of cut to black,
the transition is Lex Luthor
starts screaming and gets lit on fire.
Then they cut to five years later
and you're in the nightmare future
like everything is a wasteland on earth.
Like Batman is taking the survivors to the
Batcave or where the Batcave used to be.
Then we meet a new Green Lantern.
It's implied that it's kill
walked the dead
green Lantern from Cyborg's vision
that the mother boxes gave him.
But this is him.
When he's
first showing up to planet Earth,
his ship is crashing and he's trying to
contact someone from the Justice League.
But no one's picking up.
Batman finds him and saves them
from the rubble of the ship.
Flash shows up, helps them
destroy the rest of the demons.
Then Green Lantern explains
what's been happening
in the rest of the universe with dark side
and the anti-life equation,
how he's paving his way,
conquering the universe.
Cyborg
then reveals that he's created the cosmic
treadmill from the comics
the Flash is going to use to time travel.
But Batman's plan is word flash
travels back in time in his correctly able
to warn Batman at the right point
in time in place to save Lois Lane.
Then in present day,
Darkside starts a full scale invasion
of Earth with his fleet, like he talks
about at the end of the Snyder cut.
And they have their version of the
Avengers endgame final battle on Earth
with pretty much every character
from the DC Universe you've ever heard of.
Coming back in the way they end things
seems very similar to the Iron
Man Avengers endgame, ending with him
sacrificing himself
to snap the Infinity gantlet.
Batman winds up sacrificing himself
to land the killing, blow on dark
and destroy him completely.
Then, in the aftermath, Lois Lane
eventually gives birth to her child.
They name it Bruce Kent after Bruce Wayne
in honor of his sacrifice.
But remember, she's with Superman.
He doesn't have any power, so he doesn't
become Superboy or anything like that.
But in 20 years, there's a ceremony
where Commissioner Barbara Gordon
is honoring Batman
sacrifice 20 years before she tells Lois
when are you going to tell him,
looking at her son,
that the secret she'd been keeping
this whole time is that her son,
Bruce Kent, was secretly Bruce Wayne's
child as Batman's true son.
He winds up
taking up the mantle of the next Batman.
I don't know how
everybody feels about that.
Lois Lane giving birth to Batman's child.
One of the spiciest things I've ever
heard of them doing in a DC movie.
Then the moment you go out on
and Justice League three, like the Epilog
or the Post-Credits scene,
you see a shot of Bruce Kent in the cape
and cowl rising from the shadows in Gotham
with a bat signal shining in the sky.
There was talk a long time ago about him
doing his Justice League sequels,
but as a comic book with Jim
Lee, it's always possible
that could wind up happening.
But I'm not going to hold my breath on it.
Let me know in the comments.
They bring all those actors
back in many years for like a big crisis
on Infinite Earths movie
with a bunch of multiverse crossovers.
What do you want the actual story to be?
Do you want to just be a crisis
on infinite Earths,
or do you want them to try and do
something else?
My Shazam Fury of the Gods
Post-Credits Scene Video We'll post next.
You can click here to watch that already
at the link as soon as I post it
and click here for my Mandalorian Season
three Episode three Video.
Thank you so much for watching, everyone.
Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.